nikon qui me regardait beaucoup sur
france 4 au début sur des mythes et tu
m'as zapper à mais complètement
bah non c'est pas là ça va ma chérie
t'inquiète pas alors dis mon compte et
non parce que voilà et pour tes contre
aussi rénale qu'il était contre moi la
télé actuellement oui d'accord mais
celle donc tu voudrais quoi que je fasse
quoi du flipper tout sauf de la télé
pour éviter de voir ta tête d'accor
abattant des héros au nom non et on a
demandé à licorne devenir s'est elle dit
ce qu'elle pense voilà donc là là tu
viens cauchemar non j'ai pas un
cauchemar je suis super content de
pouvoir le dire face à face et bah ça
fait plaisir je suis quelqu'un j'aime
bien être franc exactement j'aime bien
montrer justement ce que j'ai à dire est
ce que tu veux nombreux tweets sur moi
je l'aurais chaque fois beaucoup
alors dis nous ce qui te dérange et abdi
nous pourquoi tu es contre moi à la nar
dix mois zada parce que je trouve que
les choses ont beaucoup changé depuis le
début des émissions
donc comme je disais je regardais tpm
fait depuis le début et au fur et à
mesure du temps ce qui les passe à des
beats et passe assez vite parce que bon
la chambre et changer de nom sur de plus
en plus moi je te tutoie pas ce que tu
est de la même génération que moi mais
tu vous regardez sur france 4 aussi
ouais c'est ça mais même au niveau de
l'ambiance générale des chroniqueurs ya
un malaise quoi mais alors on vient un
malaise complet mais maintenant tu dis
tu dis ce que tu mens est ce que tu
penses pas c'est plutôt les gens qui ont
changé par rapport à nous parce que
serena ambitions a eu un énorme succès
et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
gens qui se sont intéressés à l'émission
et qu'on fait peut-être que chaque chose
qui se passait dans l'émission devenait
un énorme buzz alors le buzz moi déjà je
suis un peu contre le faux buzz
oui mais dont l'effet que nous mais
laissez-nous tu vois ya beaucoup de
journalistes beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelle les [ __ ] à kasserine parce
qu'ils savent que voilà ça fait
énormément parler pour faire des
articles contre nous c'est vrai qu'ils
font que forcément aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'on fait quelque
chose c'est beaucoup plus scrutés que
lorsqu'on était sur france 4 on faisait
du bois cent cinquante mille
téléspectateurs c'est un peu normal
encore cherche tout ça on l'obtient non
mais non on cherche pas c'est vrai que
moi je trouve quand même que petit à
petit au niveau de ton comportement haut
niveau sa façon d'être des gros mots sa
façon
eh ben on ne comprend plus fameux jeu
gerra sera qui dérange pas tout où tous
les regards roma mon frère marc van well
as tout ça mais moi je comprends rien de
quoi